this is a tough joke to do as a white
comedian but here goes
because where this country is now from
where we came from is pretty remarkable
there's nothing more shameful in our
country's past than slavery okay that's
horrible
but i've grown up in a generation where
i've idolized black people my entire
life they are better at everything
so the fact that we pulled off slavery
i've already said it's awful
that's off the table
i'm just saying it's kind of neat
i mean at any point they could have been
like you know we can just run away right
and you will never catch us
and if you do we will beat the living
[ __ ] out of you
all right that's about how well that
joke should go over
there's a fine line between appreciating
the sarcasm and ooh this feels like a
rally
and you did well
that's a joke i do not do everywhere
that's a joke if the audience gets a
little too excited i shut it down
you start hearing a couple yee haw's
troubles are brewing
i just want to say i'm not trying to say
that if you're white you can't complain
right i'm just saying that if you're
black you get to complain more right
right because
you can't
there you go don't tell the band that
yeah
yeah yeah
because you can't you get this right
you can't take people's like historical
context away from them and everybody
wants this too like white people are
always like come on
it wasn't us like they want black people
to forget everything
like every year white people add 100
years to how long ago slavery was
i've heard educated white people say
slavery was 400 years ago no it very
wasn't
it was 140 years ago that's two 70 year
old ladies living and dying back-to-back
that's how recently
you could buy a guy that's right and
it's not like slavery ended and then
everything has been amazing like it just
oh glad that's all oh yeah it just ended
like a clean where you don't have to
wipe just boom and then it's just been
parades
and presents ever since
you got it
you got to remember that if you meet a
black person they have gray hair they
remember a time they weren't allowed to
use a certain toilet so give them a
little you know time to be cranky and by
the way white people have our own thing
that we stuff that we went sure
that that hurt us that we have to cope
with like when they took our slaves away
that was really hard for us
and we're still
so it's pretty even it's
so it's even yeah it's even and white
people that's slavery [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i ain't even mad at y'all about that for
real you know saying black people we be
[ __ ] with y'all about this [ __ ] cause
ain't no brother or sister in this room
that has been a slave we ain't none of
us pick no [ __ ] cotton
we wouldn't have known [ __ ] about it if
y'all hadn't made the movie roots
y'all [ __ ] up right there it wasn't
like they taught it in school chapter
seven slavery chapter eight beat a [ __ ]
ass
they never told us when that [ __ ]
movie roots came on that shocked the
[ __ ] out of every black man in this room
and when we just like what what the [ __ ]
that's how it was
you know what's that remember white
people y'all remember the next day we
came to school and beat the [ __ ] out of
y'all
i know that's a traumatic experience you
have to remember
[Applause]
and y'all gave brothers some [ __ ] up
choices man remember they used to say
well chop your dick or your foot
you know everybody's like go right here
man go right here now do what you got to
do man
you know what i'm saying that's an easy
choice to make cause you can hobble over
to some [ __ ]
you can't show up with two good legs and
no dick
that boat ride was a [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
that was some [ __ ] up ass [ __ ] man
that boat ride cause it ain't like it is
today you know what i'm saying a couple
of weeks from here to africa and these
cruises playing shuffleboard and [ __ ]
these [ __ ] was at the gully of
the ship down to bowels
you know saying chained to each other
hundreds of [ __ ] just chained
together with little diaper [ __ ] on
you know what i'm saying that was a
year-long ride
cause then we're sailing ships and the
wind don't blow all the time
you know saying you know they sitting
down there man the mother
[Music]
will you stop swinging your leg
i'm chaining you every time you swing
your leg my leg go up too
and you why you're [ __ ] all the time
i'm not the only one [ __ ]
right here
i'm telling you now you stink
i'm not the only one [ __ ] look at
you
you're taller than you were yesterday
stacking [ __ ] on top of [ __ ] on top of
[ __ ]
[Applause]
i'm saying man you gotta leave america
to grow up every time i go to india i
grow up a little bit
this last time i went to the taj mahal
and that was it was eye opening man i
don't know if anybody's ever been but
it's the most beautiful thing i've ever
seen
whole thing made a white marble
then like emeralds and sapphires and
ruby's just inlaid throughout the whole
thing took i believe 22 000 workers 20
years non-stop to build it and i'm
telling you when i went to my country
and saw my people build something like
that i realized
america completely wasted their slaves
what are you doing
this is a stupid thing to do
build something you know [ __ ]
i'm not saying slavery that slavery is
the worst i'm saying american slavery is
the war slavery
and it's all bad look when indian slaves
build the thoth mahal they cut off our
hands after so we can never make
anything that beautiful again
that's [ __ ] up
at the same time
we don't need to make anything that
beautiful again
who needs two owners of the world that's
just greedy
there's a pride you know i mean we built
that
imagine you're a jewish dude walking
through egypt looking at the pyramids
you would be like yo man that's [ __ ]
up what they did to us
but we killed that [ __ ]
you know they think aliens built those
no just a big pack of juice doing it
who says we can't do manual labor
come on
what a black people looking at to get
pride
tube socks
it's terrible man
that's why black people deserve
reparations
black americans deserve reparations
i agree man indians don't ask for them
because we already built ours
you go to the
that goes back to us
if you ever see white tourists taking
this picture
that money goes back into our pockets he
got our reparations black people don't
have them they need something
we got to figure it out i think i was
going to say that she could make money
off of underworld and underwear and
soccer michael jordan got that let him
have it
the perfect reparations for black people
i figured it out they should get 10 of
all chewing tobacco sales
it's perfect
first of all black people had to pick
[ __ ] tobacco leaves for hundreds of
years awful thing
so they should make some money on it
second
you know who loves chewing tobacco
a lot of people who don't love black
people
so one better way to make money off the
death of some racists
and i don't want to hold you back
[Music]
it was a lot like this the crowd was
like 90 white
and i was black
i mean yeah i'm still i'm i'm
and your black person on stage white
audience 200 years ago this would have
been an auction
now i did this joke which is not it's
not even a massively original
observation every black person has
considered what their life would have
been like back in the days of slavery i
also thought it wasn't going to shock
anyone because i thought we had all
agreed in the uk
that slavery was a bad idea
i thought you could find the most
right-wing person in the country some
member of the national front with a
union jack tattooed to his face
and you could ask him hey
how about we bring back slavery and even
he would go look
i want them out of my country i don't
need to own one
i thought we had consensus
but out of nowhere the pro-slavery
people started sending me angry messages
i got messages like well if you don't
like the slavery history go back to
africa monkey man
and i was like this man does not grasp
how slavery worked
was not a go back kind of situation
i hate how much fun black people can
have racially man it's just
i can say anything i goddamn want
racially and why'd you about to sit
there and take it
oh yeah i'm the evil yeah so he's like
come on man
i i don't even say it because of that i
like i i love i love a little ratio yes
look man you know
let's be fair i mean
honestly be nicer with the racial game i
mean it it i like to talk to uh you know
white people about being honest about uh
obama you gave it a shot
you did
you gave it a two year shot like oh yeah
i tried i tried to
we tried to
but you should not it's not it's just it
fell apart it really
it really did and i'm gonna tell you
something you don't know about black
folks
we would be on your side
uh then talking to white people we would
be on your side a lot more if you would
uh you know just not ever talk
about how you feel
about anything
racial will catch up to you not serious
because black people are on the edge of
going what the [ __ ] is obama doing
but it's too many white people outwardly
hating them so we can't we go if you
shut them you shut up
i'll be against them like you stop
i'm running rallies and all kinds of
stuff
i'm telling you i'm this close to
i'm mad at him because i thought i would
have a white slave but i thought
i thought it was vengeance
but i had me a white family oh big old
fat white girl go warm up better get
upstairs susan
warm my bed up feed my baby with your
giant white titties and
i'm gonna go outside and stare your
husband in the face and decide whether
i'm gonna sell them or not
and you know your wife's upstairs
warming up my bed you know that right
[Applause]
that's uncomfortable and that's
something that's uncomfortable i
apologize